hello and welcome to the tutorial on
data signs in this tutorial we are going
to see what is data signs and who is a
data scientist what are the skills of a
data scientist and what does the data
scientist do a day in the life of a data
scientist what is the methodology used
for data science like data acquisition
preparation mining and model building
and testing and then maintenance and
then towards the end we will also see an
example program as well I'll take you
through a quick goal where we have done
some data science activity and then we
will conclude so let's get started so
what is data science as the name
suggests it is nothing but study of
using data and trying to find out some
insights or extracting some insights or
knowledge using all the data that is at
your disposal so that's pretty much what
data science is all about
so you take the data and apply certain
methodologies certain algorithms and
your business domain knowledge as well
and of course a certain amount of
creativity to extract some insights very
often they are also known as actionable
insights because once you have the
insights you should be in a position to
take some action - let's say solve a
problem or improve a situation there are
a lot of areas where data science can be
used one of the very common one is fraud
detection of fraud prevention there are
a lot of fraudulent activities or
transactions primarily on the internet
it's very easy to commit fraud and
therefore we can use data science to
either prevent or detect fraud there are
certain algorithms machine learning
algorithms that can be used like for
example some outliner techniques
clustering techniques that can be used
to detect fraud and prevent fraud as
well so who is the data scientist rather
it is actually a very generic role that
defines somebody who is working with
data is known as data scientist but
there can be very specific activities
and
can be actually much more specific what
exactly a person does within the area of
data science can be much more specific
but broadly anybody working lady of data
science is known as a data scientist so
what does that data scientist do these
are some of the activities derived
position data preparation later mining
data modeling and then model maintenance
we just talked about each of these in a
great detail but at a very high level
the first step obviously is to get the
raw data which is known as data
acquisition it can be all kinds of
format and it could be multiple sources
but obviously that raw data cannot be
used as it is for performing data mining
activities or the data modeling
activities so the data has to be claimed
and prepared for using in the data
models or in the data mining activity so
that is the data preparation then we
actually do the data mining which can
also include some exploratory activities
and then if we have to do stuff like
machine learning then you need to build
a machine learning model and test the
model get insights out of it and then if
the model is fine you deploy it and then
you need to maintain the model because
over a period of time it is possible
that you need to tweak the model because
of change in the process or change in
the data and so on so that all comes
under the model maintenance so let's
take deeper look at each of these
activities let's start with data
acquisition so the stage of data
acquisition basically the data scientist
will collect raw data from all possible
sources so this could be typically an AR
DBMS which is a relational database or
it can also be a non R DBMS or it could
be flat files or unstructured data and
so on so we need to bring all that data
from different sources if required we
need to do some kind of homogeneous
formatting so that it all fits into
looks at least format from a format
perspective it looks homogeneous so that
may be requiring some kind of
transformation very often this is loaded
into what is known as data warehouse so
this can also be sometimes referred to
as ETL or extract transform and load so
our data warehouse is
a common place where data from different
sources is brought together so that
people can perform data science
activities like reporting or data mining
the statistical analysis and so on so
data from various sources is put in a
centralized place which is known as a
native bit house so that is also known
as ETL and in order to do this there can
be greatest scientists can take help of
some ETL tools there are some existing
tools that a data scientist can take
help of like for example data stage or
talent or informatica these are pretty
good tools for performing these ETL
activities and getting the data the next
stage now that you have the raw data
into a data warehouse you still probably
are not in a position to straightaway
use this data for performing the data
mining activities so that is where data
preparation comes into play and there
are multiple reasons for that one of
them could be the data is dirty there
are some missing values and so on and so
forth so a lot of time is actually spent
in this particular state so a data
scientist spends a lot of time almost
sixty to seventy percent of the time in
this part of the project or the process
which is data preparation so there are
again within this there can be multiple
sub activities starting from let's say
data cleaning you will probably have
missing values the data there is some
columns the values are missing or the
values are incorrect there are null
values and so on and so forth so that is
basically the data cleaning part of it
then you need to perform certain
transformations like for example
normalizing the data and so on right so
all you could probably have to modify a
categorical values into numerical values
and so on and so forth so these are
transformational activities then we may
have to handle outliers so the data
could be such that there are a few
values which are way beyond the normal
behavior of the data for whatever reason
either people have keyed in wrong values
or for some reason some of the values
are completely out of range
so those are known as outliers so there
are certain ways of handling these
outliers
detecting and handling these outliers so
this is a part of what is known as
exploratory analysis so you quickly
explore the data to find out other so
and you can use visual tools like plots
and identify what are the outliers and
see how we can get rid of the outliers
and so on
then the next part could be data
integrity data integrity is to validate
for example if there are some primary
keys that all the primary keys are
populated there are some foreign keys
and at least most of the foreign keys
should be populated and otherwise when
we are trying to query the data you may
get wrong values and so on so that is
the data integrity part of it and then
we have what is known as data reduction
sometimes they may have duplicate values
we may have columns that may be
duplicated because they are coming from
different sources the same value sir
there and so on so a lot of this can be
done using what is known as data
reduction and thereby you can reduce the
size of the data drastically because
very often because this could be written
and data which can be removed so let's
take a look at what are the various
techniques that are used for later
cleaning so we need to ensure that the
data is valid and it is consistent and
uniform and accurate so these are the
various parameters that we need to
ensure as a part of the data cleaning
process now what are the techniques that
that are used for data cleaning or route
so we will see what each of these are in
this particular case and so what is the
data set that we have we have data about
a bank and its customer details so let's
take an example and see how we go about
cleaning the data and in this particular
example we are assuming we are using
fiber so let's assume we loaded this
data which is the raw file dot CSV this
is all the customer data looks like and
we will see for example we take a closer
look at the geography column we will see
that there are quite a few blank spaces
so how do we go about when we have some
blank spaces or if it is a string value
then we put a empty string here
or we just use a space or empty string
if there are numerical values then we
need to come up with a strategy for
example we put the mean value so
wherever it is missing
we find the mean for that particular
column so in this case let's assume we
have credit score and we see that quite
a few of these values are missing so
what do we do here
we find the mean for this column for all
the existing values and we found that
the mean is equal to six thirty eight
point six so we kind of write a piece of
code to replace wherever there are blank
values n n is basically like null and we
just go ahead and say fill it with the
mean way so this is a piece of code we
are writing to fill it so all the blanks
or all the null values get replaced with
the mean value now one of the reasons
for doing this is that very often if you
have some such situation many of your
statistical functions may not even work
so that's the reason you need to fill up
these values or either get rid of these
records or fill up these values with
something meaningful so this is one
mechanism which is basically using a
mean there are a few others as we move
forward we can see what are the other
ways for example we can also say that
any missing value in a particular row if
even one column the value is missing you
just drop that particular row or delete
all rows where even a single column has
missing values so that is one way of
dealing now the problem here can be that
if a lot of data has let's say one or
two columns missing and we dropped many
such rows then overall you may lose out
on let's say 60% of the data has some
value or the other missing 60 percent of
the rows then it may not be a good idea
to delete all the rows like in that
manner because then you are losing
pretty much 60 percent of your data
therefore your analysis won't be
accurate but if it is only five or ten
percent then this will work under way is
only to drop values where or rather drop
rows where all the columns are empty
which makes sense because that means
that record is of really no use because
it has no information in it so there can
be some situation
like that so we can provide a condition
saying that drop the records where all
the columns are blank or not applicable
we can also specify some kind of a
threshold let's say you have 10 or 20
columns in a row you can specify that
maybe five columns are blank or null
then you drop that record so again we
need to take care that such a condition
such a situation the amount of data that
has been removed or excluded it's not
large if it is like maybe five percent
maximum ten percent then it's okay
but by doing this if you are losing out
on a large chunk of data then it may not
be a good idea you need to come up with
something better what else we need to do
next is the data preparation part is
done so now we get into the data mining
part so what exactly we do in data
mining primarily we come up with ways to
take meaningful decisions so data mining
will give us insights into the data what
is existing there and then we can do
additional stuff like maybe machine
learning and so on to get perform
advanced analytics and so on so one of
the first steps we do is what is known
as data discovery and which is basically
like exploratory analysis so we can use
tools like tableau for doing some of
this so let's just take a quick look at
how we go about that so tableau has
excellent data mining or actually more
of a reporting or a bi tool and you can
download a trial version of tableau at
tableau comm or there is also a tableau
public which is free and you can
actually use and play around however if
you want to use it for enterprise
purpose than it is commercial software
so you need to purchase license and you
can then run some of the data mining
activities say your data source your
data is in some excel sheet so you can
select the source as Microsoft Excel or
any other format and the data will be
brought into the tableau environment and
then it will show you what is known as
dimensions and measures so dimensions
are all the descriptive columns so and
tableau is intelligent enough to
actually identify these dimensions
and measures so measures of the
numerical life so as you can see here
customer ID gender geography these are
all dimensions monument to values
whereas H balance credit score and so on
are never equal you so they come under
measures so you got your data into
tableau and then you want to let's say
build a small model and you want to
let's say solve a particular problem so
what is the problem statement all right
let's say we want to analyze why
customers are leaving the back which is
known as exit and we want to analyze and
see what are some of the factors for
exiting the bank and we want to let's
assume consider these three of them like
let's say gender credit card and
geography these as a criteria and
analyze if these are in any way
impacting or have some bearing on the
customer exiting or the customer exit
behavior okay so let's use tableau and
very quickly we will be able to find out
how these parameters are affecting
alright so let's see so this is our
customer data so from excel sheet we
dataset about let's say 10,000 goes and
we want to find out what is the criteria
let's start with gender let's say we
want to first use gender as a criteria
so tableau really offers an easy
drag-and-drop kind of a mechanism so
that makes it really really easy to
perform this kind of analysis so what we
need to do is exited says whether the
customer has exited or not so it has a
value of 0 and 1 and then of course you
have gender and so on so we will take
these two and simply drag and drop ok so
exited and then we will put gender and
if we drag and drop into the analysis
side of tableau alright so here what we
are doing is we are showing male female
as two different columns here and 0 for
people who did not exist and one for
people who exited and that is color
coded so the blue color means people who
did not exit and this yellow color means
people who did exit all right so now if
we pull the data here create like bar
graphs this is how it would look so what
is yellow let's go
so yellow is who exited and for the male
only sixteen point four five person tab
exited and we can also draw a reference
line that will help us or even provide
aliases so these are a lot of fancy
stuff that is provided by tableau you
can create aliases and so that it looks
good rather than basic labels and you
can also add a reference line so you add
a reference line something like this
from here we can make out that on an
average female customers exit more than
the male customers and so that is what
we are seeing here on an average so we
have analyzed based on gender we do see
that there is some difference in the
male and female behavior now let's take
the next criteria which is the credit
card so let's see if having a credit
card has any impact on the customer exit
behavior so just like before we drag and
drop the credit card has credit card or
column if we drag and drop here and then
we will see that there is pretty much no
difference between people having credit
card and not having credit card twenty
point eight one percent of people who
have no credit card have exited and
similarly twenty point one eight percent
of people who have credit card
I have also exited so the credit card is
not having much of an impact that's what
this piece of analysis shows last we
will basically go and check how the
geography is impacting so once again we
can drag and drop job if we call them
onto this side and if we see here there
are geographies like that I think there
are about three geographies like France
Germany and Spain and we see that there
is some kind of impact with the
geography as well ok so what we derived
from this is that the credit card is
really we can ignore the credit card
variable feature from our analysis
because that doesn't have any impact but
gender and geography we can keep and do
further analysis ok all right so what
are some of the advantages of data
mining bit more detailed analysis can
help us in predicting the future trends
and it also helps in identifying
customer behavior patterns okay so you
can take informed decisions because the
data is telling you or providing you
with some insights and then you take a
decision based on that if there is any
fraudulent activity data mining will
help in quickly identifying such a fraud
as well and of course it will also help
us in identifying the right algorithm
for performing more advanced data mining
activities like machine learning and so
on all right so the next activity now
that we have the data we have prepared
the data and perform some data mining
activity the next step is model building
let's take a look at model building so
what is model building if we want to
perform a more detailed data mining
activity like maybe perform some machine
learning then you need to build a model
and how do you build a model first thing
is you need to select which algorithm
you want to use to solve the problem on
hand and also what kind of data that is
available and so on and so forth so you
need to make a choice of the algorithm
and based on that you go ahead and
create a model train the model and so on
now machine learning is kind of at a
very high level classified into
supervised and unsupervised so if we
want to predict a continuous value could
be a price or a temperature or or a
height or length of things like that so
those are continuous values and if you
want to find some of those then you use
techniques like regression linear
regression simple linear regression
multiple linear regression and so on so
these are the algorithms on the other
hand there will be situations or there
may be situations where you need to
perform unsupervised learning case of
unsupervised learning you don't have any
historical labeled data so to learn from
so that is when you use on supervised
learning and some of the algorithms in
unsupervised learning are clustering
k-means clustering is the most common
algorithm used in unsupervised learning
and similarly in supervised learning if
you want to perform some activity on
categorical values like for example that
is not measured but it is
count it like you want to classify
whether this image is a cat or a dog
whether you want to classify whether
this customer will buy the product or
not or even want to classify whether
this email is spam or not spam so these
are examples of categorical values and
these are examples of classification
then you have algorithms like logistic
regression K nearest neighbor or KN and
support vector machine so these are some
of the algorithms that are used in this
case and similarly in case of
unsupervised learning if you need to
perform on categorical values you have
some algorithms like Association
analysis and hidden Markov model okay so
in order to understand this better let's
take an example and take you through the
whole process and then we will also see
how the code can be written to perform
this now let's take our example here
where we want to perform the supervised
learning which is basically we want to
do a multi linear regression which means
there are multiple independent variables
and then you want to perform a linear
regression to predict certain value so
in this particular example we have world
happiness data so this is the data about
the happiness quotient of people from
various countries and we are trying to
predict and see whether our how our
model will perform so what is the
question that we need to ask first of
all how to describe the data and then
can we make a predictive model to
calculate the happiness score right so
based on this we can then decide on what
algorithm to use and what model to use
and so on so variables that are
available or used in this model this is
a list of variables that are available
there is a happiness rankled load the
data and I'll show you the data in a
little bit so it becomes clear what are
these so there is what is known as a
Happiness ranked happiness core which is
happiness score is more like absolute
value whereas rank is what is the
ranking and then which country we are
talking about and within that country
which region and what kind of economy
and the family which Family and health
details and freedom transgender ASSA T
and so on and so forth so there are
multiple variables that are available to
us and
the specific details probably are not
required and there can be in another
example the variables can be completely
different so we don't have to go into
the details of what exactly these
variables are but just enough to
understand that we have a bunch of these
variables and now we need to use either
all or some of these variables and then
which we also sometimes referred to as
features and then we need to build our
model and train our model all right so
let's assume we will use Python in order
to perform this analysis or perform this
machine learning activity and I will
actually show you in our lab in a little
bit this whole thing we will run the
live code but quickly I will run you
through the slides and then we will go
into the lab so what are we doing here
our first thing we need to do is import
a bunch of libraries in Python which are
required to perform our analysis most of
these are for manipulating the data of
the preparing the data and then
scikit-learn or s kala is the library
which we will use actually for this
particular machine learning activity
which is linear regression so we have
numpy via pandas and so on and so forth
so all these libraries are imported and
then we load our data and the data is in
the form of a CSV file and there are
different files for each year so we have
data for 2015 16 and 17 and so we will
load this data and then combine them
concatenate them to prepare a single
data frame and here we are making an
assumption that you are familiar with
Python so it becomes easier if you are
familiar with Python programming
language or at least some programming
language so that you can at least
understand by looking at the code so we
are reading the file each of these files
for each year and this is basically we
are creating up a list of all the names
of the columns we will be using later on
you will see in the code so we have
loaded 2015 then 2016 and then also 2070
so we have created three data frames and
then we concatenate all these three data
frames this is what we are doing here
then we identify which of these columns
are required which for example some of
the categorical values do we really need
we probably don't then we drop those
columns so that we don't necessarily use
all the columns and make the computation
complicated we can then create some
plots using plotly library and it has
some powerful features including
creation or creation of maps and so on
just to understand the pattern the
happiness quotient or how the happiness
is across all the countries so it's a
nice visualization we can see each of
these countries how they are in terms of
their happiness score this is the legend
here so the lighter colored countries
have lower ranking and so these are the
lower ranking ones and these are higher
ranking which means that the ones with
these dark colors are the happiest ones
so as you can see here Australia and
maybe this side us and so on are the
happiest ones okay the other thing that
we need to do is the correlation between
the Happiness score and Happiness rank
we can find a correlation using the
scatterplot and we find that yes they
are kind of inversely proportional it is
obvious so if the score is high
happiness score is high then they are
ranked number one for exam
highest is scored as number one so
that's I get behind this so the
Happiness score given here and the
happiness rank is actually even here so
they are inversely proportional because
the higher the score the absolute value
of the rank will be lower ranks number
one has the highest value of the score
and so on so they are inversely
correlated but there is a strong what
this graph shows is that there is a
strong correlation between happiness
rank and Happiness score and then we do
some more plots to visualize this we
determine that probly rank and score are
pretty much conveying the same message
so we don't need both of them so we will
kind of drop one of them and that is
what we are doing here so we drop the
happiness rank and similarly so this is
one example of how we can remove some
columns which are not adding value so we
will see in the code as well how that
works
moving on this is a correlation between
pretty much each of the columns with the
other columns so this is a correlation
we can plot using plot function and
we will see here that for example
happiness score and Happiness score are
correlated strongest correlation right
because every variable will be highly
correlated to itself so that's the
reason so the darker the color is the
higher the correlation and as so the and
correlation in numerical terms goes from
0 to 1 so 1 is the highest value and it
can only be between 0 & 1 correlation
between two variables can be only have a
value between 0 & 1 so the numerical
value can go from 0 to 1 and 1 here is
dark color and 0 is kind of locked but
it is blue color from red it goes down
the dark blue color indicates pretty
much no correlation so the from this
heat map we see that happiness and
economy and family are probably also
health probably are the most correlated
and then it keeps decreasing after
freedom kind of keeps decreasing and
coming to pretty much see all right so
that is a correlation graph and then we
can probably use this to find out which
are the columns that need to be dropped
and you do not have very high
correlation and we take only those
columns that we will need so this is the
code for dropping some of the columns
once we have prepared the data when we
have the required columns then we use
scikit-learn
to actually speak the rate of asphalt
this is a normal machine learning
process you need to split the data into
training and test data set in this case
we are splitting into 80 20 so 80 is the
training data set and 20 is the test
data set so that's what we are doing
here so we use trained test method or
function so you have all your training
data in X underscore train the labels in
y underscore train similarly X
underscore test has the test data the
inputs whereas the labels are in y
underscore test so that's all and this
value whether it is 80/20 or 50/50 that
is all individual preference so in our
case we are using 80/20 all right and
then the next is to create a linear
regression instance so this is what we
are doing we are creating an instance of
linear regression and then
we train the model using the fit
function and we are passing x and y
which is the x value and the label data
regular input and the label data label
information then we do the test we run
the or we perform the evaluation on the
test data set so this is what we are
doing with the test data set and then we
will evaluate how accurate the model is
and using the scikit-learn functionality
itself we can also see what are the
various parameters and what are the
various coefficients because in linear
regression you will get like equation of
like a straight line y is equal to beta
0 plus beta 1 x 1 plus beta 2 x 2 so
those theta 1 theta 2 theta 3 are known
as the coefficients and beta 0 is the
intercept after the training you can
actually get these information of the
model what is the intercept value what
are the coefficients and so on by using
these functions so let's take quickly go
into the lab and take a look at our code
ok so this is my lab this is my jupiter
notebook where the code i have the
actual code and i will take you through
the score to run this linear regression
on the world happiness data so we will
import a bunch of libraries number and a
lot plotly and so on also a scikit-learn
that's also very important so that's the
first step then i will import my data
and the data is in three parts there are
three files one for each year 2015 2016
and 2017 and it is a csv file so i have
imported my data let's take a look at
the data quickly Landsat data so this is
how it looks we have the country region
happiness rank and then happiness score
there are some standard errors and then
what is a fur cap it family and so on so
there we go keep going we will create a
list of all these column names we will
be using later so for now just I will
run this code and no need of
explanation at this point we know that
some of these columns probably are not
required so you can use this drop
functionality to remove some of the
columns which we don't need like for
example region and standard error will
not be contributing to our model so we
will basically drop those values out
here so we use the drop and then we
created a vector of it these names
column names that's what we are passing
here instead of giving the names of the
columns here we can pass a vector so
that's what we are doing so this will
drop from our data frame it will remove
region and standard error these two
columns then the next step we will read
the data for 2016 and also 2017 and then
we will concatenate this data so let's
do that so we have now data frame called
happiness which is a concatenation of
both all three files let's take a quick
look at the data now so most of the
unwanted columns have been removed and
you have all the data in one place for
all the three years and this is all the
data logs and if you want to take a look
at the summary of the columns you can
say describe and you will get this
information for example for each of the
columns what is the count which what is
the mean value standard deviation
especially the numeric values not the
categorical values so this is a quick
way to see how the data is and initial
little bit of exploratory analysis can
be done here so what is the maximum
value of the minimum value and so on for
each of the columns alright so then we
go ahead and create some visualizations
using plotly so let us go and build a
plot so if we see here now this is the
relation correlation between happiness
rank and happiness score this is what we
have seen in the slides as well we can
see that there is a tight correlation
between them only thing is it is inverse
correlation but otherwise they are very
tightly correlated which also says that
they both probably provide the same
information so there is no not much of
value add so we will go ahead and drop
the happiness rank as well from our
columns
and now we can do the creation of the
correlation heatmap let us plot the
correlation heat map to see how each of
these columns is correlated to the
others and we as we have seen in the
slides this is how it looks so Happiness
score is very highly correlated so this
is the legend we have seen in the slide
as well so blue color indicates pretty
much zero or very low correlation deep
red color indicates very high
correlation and the value correlation is
a numeric value and the value goes from
zero to one if the two items or two
features or columns are highly
correlated then there will be as close
to one as possible and two columns that
are not at all correlated will be as
close to zero as possible so that's how
it is for example here happiness score
and Happiness score every column or
every feature will be highly correlated
to itself so it is like between them
there will be correlation value will be
one so that's why we see deep red color
but then others are for example with
higher values our economy and then
health and then maybe family and freedom
so these are generosity and Trust are
not very highly correlated to happiness
score so that is one quick and
exploratory analysis we can do and
therefore we can drop the country and
happiness rank because they also again
don't have any major impact on the
analysis on our analysis so now we have
prepared our data there was no need to
clean the data because the data was
clean but if there were some missing
values and so on as we have discussed in
the slide so you would have had to
perform some of the data cleaning
activities as well but in this case the
data was clean all we needed to do was
just the preparation part so we remove
some unwanted columns and we did some
exploratory data analysis now we are
ready to perform the machine learning
activity so we use scikit-learn
for doing the machine learning
scikit-learn is vital library that is
available for performing our machine
learning once again we will import some
of these libraries like pandas and numpy
and
also psychic learn first step we will do
is split the data in 20/80 format so you
have all the test data which is 20% of
the data is test data and 80% is your
training data so this test size
indicates how much of it is the what is
the size of the test data remaining
which is here we assign point to
therefore that means training is point
eight so training data is 80 percent all
right so we have executed that split the
data and now we create an instance of
the linear regression model so LM is our
linear regression model and we pass x
and y the training data set and call the
function fit so that the model gets
trained so now once that is done
training is done training is completed
and now what we have to do is we need to
predict the values for the test data so
the next step is using so you see your
fit will basically run the training
method predict will actually predict the
values so we are passing the input
values which is the independent
variables and we are asking for the
values of the dependent variable which
is which we are capturing in Y
underscore pry and we use the predict
method here LM not predict so this will
give us all the predicted Y values and
remember we already have y underscore
test has the actual values which are the
labels so that we can use these two to
compare and find out how much of it is
error so that's what we are doing here
we are trying to find the difference
between the predicted value and the
actual value y underscore test is the
actual value for the test data and Y
underscore predict is the predicted
value we just found out the predicted
line so we will run that and we can do a
quick check as to how the data looks how
is the difference so in some cases it is
positive some cases it is negative but
in most of the cases I think the
difference is very small this is
exponential to the power of 0 minus 0 4
and so on
so looks like our model has performed
reasonably well we can now check some of
the parameters of our model like the
intercept and the coefficients so that's
what we are doing here so these are the
coefficients of the various parameters
that we are the coefficients of the
various independent variables so
so these are the values then we can
quickly go ahead and list them down as
well against the corresponding
independent variable so the coefficients
against the corresponding independent
variable so one point zero zero five one
is the coefficient for economy point
nananana tree is for family coefficient
for family and health and so on and so
forth so that's what this is showing now
we can use the functionality readily
available functionality of scikit-learn
and then plot that to find some of the
parameters which determine the accuracy
of this model like for example what is
the mean square error and so on so
that's what we are doing here so let's
just go ahead and run this so you can
see here that the root mean square error
is pretty low which is a good sign and
which is one of the measures of how well
our model is performing we can do one
more quick plot to just see how the
actual values and the predicted values
are looking and once again you can see
that as we have seen from the root mean
square error is very very low that means
that the actual values and the predicted
values are pretty much matching up
almost matching up and this plot also
shows the same so this line is going
through the predicted values and actual
values and the difference is very very
low so again this is actually this is
one example where the accuracy is high
and the predicted values are pretty much
matching with the actual values but in
real life you may find that these values
are slightly more scattered and you may
get the error value can be relatively on
the higher side the root mean square
error okay so this was a good quick
example of the code to perform data
science activity you are a machine
learning or data mining activity in this
case we did what is known as linear
regression so let's go back to our
slides and see what else is there so we
saw this these are the coefficients of
each of the features in our code and we
have seen the root mean square error as
well and we can take us few hundred
countries certain values and actually
predict to see if how the model is
performing and I think we have done this
as well
and in this case as we have seen the
prima
the predicted values and actual values
are pretty much matching which means our
model is almost hundred percent accurate
as I mentioned it real-life it may not
be the case but in this particular case
we have got a pretty good model which is
very good also subsequently we can
assume that this is our the equation in
linear regression the model is nothing
but an equation like y is equal to beta
0 plus beta 1 X 1 plus beta 2 X 2 plus
beta 3 X 3 and so on so this is what we
are showing here so this is our
intercept which is beta 0 and then we
have beta 1 into economy value beta 2
into the family value beta 3 into health
value and so on so that is what is shown
here ok so I think the next step once we
have the results from the data mining or
machine learning activity the next step
is to communicate these results to the
appropriate stakeholders so that is what
we will see here now so how do we
communicate usually you take these
results and then either prepare a
presentation or put it in a document and
then show them these actionable results
or actionable insights and you need to
find out who are your target audience
and put all the results in context and
maybe if there was a problem statement
you need to put those results in the
context of the problem statement what
was our initial goal that we wanted to
achieve so that we need to communicate
here based on you remember we started
off with what is the question and what
is the data and so on and then what is
the answer so we we need to put the
results and then what is the methodology
that we have used all that has to be put
and clearly communicated in business
terms so that the people understand very
well from a business perspective so once
the model building is done once the
results are published and communicated
the last part is maintenance of this
model now very often what can happen is
the model may have to be subsequently
updated or modified because of multiple
reasons either the the data has changed
the way the data comes has changed or
the process has changed of
whatever reason the accuracy may keep
changing once you have a train the model
the example we got a very high accuracy
but then over a period of time there can
be various factors which can cause that
so from time to time we need to check
whether the model is performing well or
not the accuracy needs to be tested once
in a while and if required you may have
to rebuild or retrain the model so you
do the assessment you you see if it
needs any tweaks or changes and then if
it is required you need to probably
retrain the model with latest data that
you have and then you deploy it you
build the model train it and then you
deploy it so that is like the
maintenance cycle that you may have to
take the model through all right so we
are pretty much at the end of our
tutorial so what did we learn in this
tutorial we talked about what is data
science and who is the data scientist
then we talked about what a data
scientist performs or does or day in the
life of a data scientist some of the
activities or the methodology is like
the processes another data acquisition
did a preparation a mining and model
building and so on and then last but not
least the model maintenance and in the
process we have also taken a look at the
Python code that was used for performing
a linear regression model creating a
linear regression model training it and
testing it and checking the various
parameters of the model with that we
come to the end of this tutorial
I hope you enjoyed it if you have any
questions or comments put it below the
video in the comment section we were
more than happy to respond actually if
you leave your email address I would
like to thank you once again and have a
great day thank you and bye
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here